[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça découvre la
Réunion ensemble ça dépend alors
allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune du Tampon plus
précisément à
boiscourantes
Monsieur juste
un peu bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur
comment elle est ça va bien tout le
monde
ici d'accord et comment ça se nana
beaucoup de travaux comme ça
ok ça on aura des kiosque
chanter ici en face
d'accord et ça sera plus agréable pour
peu de Moon voilà ça c'est plus sûr ok
sera plus sûr
pour les bus et tout et bah les gars
le mal que la femelle parce que le mal
lui peut mettre plein jusqu'à 8 femelles
par jour donc le mal est autant
important que la femelle et le mâle en
puisse a beaucoup plus loin pour les
chaleurs qu'on a Charlotte femelle quoi
d'accord et aujourd'hui par rapport à
cette sensibilisation là est-ce que nous
connais combien d'espèces n'a été sauvé
ou combien d'espèces ben là on est à peu
près à 50 couples reproducteurs de
pétrainement de Bourbon c'est pas
beaucoup hein en sachant que un chat
s'il se retrouve sur une colonie peux-tu
jusqu'à 90 de ces oiseaux là en une
saison de reproduction de cet oiseau
qu'il faut faire là bas c'est essayer de
balle limiter la prolifération de champ
forêt pour essayer de protéger l'oiseau
alors que ça nous va sur ce magnifique
point de vue un petit peu alors si nous
garde là bas
le coteau descendre et là haut le fameux
sentier Jacky ignare mais dans tout ça
nous destination finale il est juste en
bas là-bas
des villages de grands bassin et sinon
retourne encore ici nous on va voir la
cascade
[Musique]
rien que ça même moins dépenses avoir si
l'on retrouve mon moment rien que la
même moquette
[Musique]
comme si la nature déconné ah la la
paradis pour nous rester
[Musique]
vous venez d'où comme ça là moi je viens
de métropole de Paris moi je viens de
Bordeaux d'accord et toi moi j'habite
ici là et comment ça se fait vous voulez
vous êtes en vacances ici vous
exactement
à Grand-Bassin c'est ça et ça fait une
petite baignade
d'accord alors vous êtes vous êtes en
vacances c'est quoi le la suite du
programme demain c'est ma fête demain
avec une petite nuit en gîte samedi
dimanche d'accord et puis après on verra
il restera trois quatre jours on verra
si on fait plutôt des neiges et puis
plage parce que la Réunion
plage tous les après-midi c'est prévu ça
alors grand bassin du coup en mode en
mode de randonnée ça donne quoi en mode
trailer ça donne quoi
voilà on l'a fait plutôt cool c'est
plutôt de la randonnée que du coup
je crois donc c'est une bonne mise en
route pour pour demain
bon moi je vais descendre ça va la des
sentiments
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène parle pas nous aller nous verrez
la même un peu le respect pour mon pays
la même vraiment la pré depuis son lit
au-delà et ben voilà ben moi voilà
arrive au village embêtant ça c'est
magnifique
bonjour madame bonjour comment
allez-vous ça va merci alors dites moi
je vois vous descendez comme ça vous
arrivez d'où là oui ben en fait je viens
du village un petit peu plus haut je
fais la randonnée de Grand-Bassin sur la
journée l'aller-retour ah oui quand même
c'est super joli c'est vrai ouais le
cadre est vraiment magnifique ça faisait
un petit moment que je voulais la faire
en plus donc bah c'est vrai que c'est
mythique puisque comme ma fat c'est le
seul il est où il y a pas de transport
il y a pas d'accès en voiture donc c'est
c'est quand même original et authentique
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez vu un
petit peu dans les villages du coup
alors ben en fait c'est vrai qu'il y a
pas mal de il y a pas mal de gîtes il y
a la petite chapelle c'est magnifique on
a vu des bah après il y a les
passerelles il y a les sentiers sont
sont superbes et du coup le fait de
venir dans un village que vous aviez qui
ressemble d'ailleurs le petit Mafac
isolé comme ça qu'est-ce que ça vous
fait ah c'est un sentiment de calme de
tranquillité que effectivement on a un
peu moins dans les autres grandes villes
parce que là par exemple je venais de
Saint-Leu et c'est juste pour avoir un
petit moment de de calme de sérénité de
repos enfin c'est super agréable bonne
remontée à vous merci ma poule et en
tout cas moi il va aller par là allez
allez
ça magnifique cascade et nous l'avons
préserve une pétrir noir de bois bon ok
la réunion n'a gagné
et pour ça rendez vous à la prochaine
épisode de l'émission à Loulou cette
fois-ci on va les découvrir la forêt de
l'État ici derrière la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]